we start by saying congrats on the movie
and you loved it made me laugh a tonton
last night I remember I'm out that's all
I have
all right well thank you go see longshot
in theaters May 3rd I think we first
interviewed like 10 years ago what ask
you when yeah it was for whack white
Sundance yeah when you were make when
you were promoting that movie like yeah
way back when yeah was this the dream to
finally like like cuz you've had now a
very successful career yeah you know did
you talk a little bit about making it
well it seemed like the way that ties
into this movie you know cuz I think
that that's a thing that like Ceph
provides for Charlize his character is
like who did you want to be when you
were younger like what did you want to
be doing like obviously you're doing the
thing that you wanted to be doing but
are you doing it in the way you want to
be doing it and for sure Lisa's
character it's like you know she is
incredibly successful but she's made a
bunch of compromises and he knows her
when she was 15 and and knows that she
wouldn't be like that happy with that
for me I mean I constantly ask myself
the question of who did you know even
before the Wackness what did I want to
be doing and I think that you know to
know I've made a lot of movies since
then that I'm incredibly proud of and
this is like one of the ones that I'm
the most proud of so you know you never
know where kind of that your career is
gonna take you but I always wanted to
make you know I grew up on movies that
were like big pop-culture original
stories big pop culture movies that you
needed to see in a movie theater and
those are the movies I always wanted to
make and so this like yeah like young me
was watching When Harry Met Sally over
and over again and pretty woman over and
over again and so the opportunity to
make something in the same vein yeah I
think Wackness me would have been
psyched who knows I have to say that I
really enjoyed your portrayal of Wimbley
news yes how close did you ever think
effort let's just go with Fox News or
was it always like a play no I mean I
think that that was like something that
was important to making this movies was
to be like reflective of reality but
just far enough away that we didn't
inject too much anger or outrage into
the overall kind of holistic tone of the
movie because it's really hard
- - you know I can blend tones pretty
well but I can't blend like anger and
romance you know and so we wanted to be
able to explore and provide some insight
into contemporary politics and
contemporary media and stuff like that
but we also didn't want to do it to the
point where it was overwhelming the
sweetness of the movie when you have
Seth you obviously have a so many
multiple alt takes yeah what the hell is
it like in the editing room when you're
working with someone like this um you
know it's it's interesting because not
only do we have all takes we have you
know we have writers on set who are
writing stuff for him too and of course
he's writing stuff for himself all the
time it's not really hard like they it
all cuts together because we use two
cameras just the same way we're using
two cameras right now not to peel behind
the curtain but there's a grammar there
and a camera there so it all cuts
together it's just oh I'm talking about
like how he how you pick it whoa like
cuz he'll probably deliver three great
lines yeah and you're like all three of
these are my shot yeah how do I pick
which well it'll quickly Whittle you
Whittle it down right so at the very
beginning we had a four and a half hour
cut that was interminably long and
probably not that funny and then you
start by getting rid of the ones that
you know are like not good and then you
go and then you just like get to like
them you get rid of the c-level jokes
and then you're all be level jokes and
then you test it for people and you
quickly find that the jokes you thought
were super funny most people don't so
you get rid of those and then you're
left with a category of jokes
that's like they're all pretty funny
some of them you know you get rid of the
ones that aren't necessarily moving the
story forward and then every and you get
rid of the ones that a lot of people
aren't laughing at but then you have
ones that you kind of just cling on to
because you like them and I think that
you know after having made like a few
studio comedies on this one I was more
inclined to hold on to ones that I just
happened to like so you mentioned a
four-and-a-half-hour for first cup yeah
is that like where you have that's
literally everything yeah I mean they
have to put everything the editor has to
put everything in but yeah something
like that is it like does it have a lot
of alt jokes in that cut or that's just
like the cut with those jokes they'll
usually have
to pick a joke you know because you get
to a four-and-a-half-hour cut if you
it's a long yeah it's a long it's a long
yeah though but because it's not just
picking an all joke for a moment then
there's like a whole run of a scene that
you end up cutting or whole scenes that
you end up cutting so yeah I mean it's
it's that that's the hardest thing when
you sit down for the four-and-a-half
hour cut you how it actually took a
month before I could watch the movie in
one setting so until it gets to be under
three hours you really can't watch it in
one setting you don't really know what
you have but you do know like it's
actually the most wonderful thing in the
world to get a four and a half hour cut
because you're like watching and you're
like there's got to be an hour to half a
good [ __ ] in here right so that's that's
how it's the longer the first cut I find
the better the movie I'm gonna say
because I often ask people filmmakers
about how long was your first cut
deleted scenes like this is a stable of
questions I always ask yeah it is rare
for me to hear four and a half hours I
hear a lot three something yeah I'm
trying to think if I ever heard of
another four and have her I think this
is the end was like five our first cut
it's just about like we had so many
characters and we had so many different
you know we're balancing so much stuff
and we're also trying to make it as
funny as possible that it just you know
it just it got it got big yeah I'm still
curious I gotta go but I'm so curious
some of the stuff that was cut out for a
follow up yeah yeah I mean I think some
of it will appear online you know there
was an opening scene
I'll just there was an opening scene
where I'm - we we established Charlize
as character as like considered like
much more interested in sort of style
than substance you know much more
interested in optics than the actual
substance of diplomacy so there's a
scene where she signs a deal like a
treaty with the Japanese Foreign
Minister and they celebrate by like
having doing the photo-op is that they
both sing karaoke together and so I know
Charlie was really pissed at me because
she really didn't want to sing karaoke
and we ended up cutting it because it
was like tonally I mean that was that's
another thing is like in the editing
process your tone starts to get formed a
little bit more and this movie had a lot
less of like a silly tone than other
movies we've done in the past we it
quickly became clear that the tone of
this movie
we were cutting more jokes in in post
than we had before because this movie we
felt could work as a story and a
character based kind of romance as well
as it did a comedy so we ended up kind
of forming the tone a little bit more in
in post on this movie than we had in the
past